Samuel Leeds is one of Britain's most
successful property entrepreneurs a
high-flying investor a best-selling
author and founder of a leading property
education company Samuel is recognized
as one of the brightest young stars in
British business following his meteoric
rise to success by becoming a
multi-millionaire in his twenties Samuel
is in the elite echelons of UK property
investors over the next five weeks
thirteen burning property entrepreneurs
will be battling it out to prove that
they are the ultimate property investor
the prize 20,000 pounds of Samuels cold
hard cash to kick-start one candidates
property journey this is the
[Music]
previously on the eviction good morning
and welcome to the eviction I think it's
going to quite challenging for Vickie
it's not really well just feel ignored I
know that's your event here though this
is the fourth time I'm asking how much
money who's going maybe to go with the
girls didn't close the deal I can't
remember anything from stupid you were
cocky Steve with your breath you're a
fictive you're messed up your numbers
were all wrong Elliott I think you're
going to do very well in business and in
life and it was deep regret that you are
predicted
[Music]
so yesterday you all made it through to
the second round so congratulations and
the challenge was to sell and package a
property deal which both teams achieved
the problem with a lot of deal packages
in today is that they over promised in
order to sell the property which can
result in down the line problems now the
boys sold their deal on the basis that
the refurb cost could be just two
thousand pound and the girls
you sold your property and you said that
for a refurb it'll be eleven seventy so
your challenge is and say your team
leader here is your eleven seventy in
cash you have until Monday at 5:00 p.m.
to refurb the property it will then be
inspected by the buyer and the outcome
has to be that they are happy with what
you've promised understood
boys Ricky you are our team leader
there's 2,000 pounds cash there are the
keys Monday 5:00 p.m. the investor that
bought your property will be inspecting
it and expecting it to be at a good
level as promised understood we're going
to mix the team's slightly because well
firstly James it was said that James was
quite hard-nosed arrogant and cocky
so James to Humble you and soften you a
little bit we're going to move you to
the girls team now there's a little bit
of an imbalance in the teams in the
numbers so in order to even the numbers
out a little bit I'm going to ask Alicia
and Hannah to move over to the boys team
please an important part of being a
property entrepreneur he's been able to
sell but is also being able to deliver
and overseeing a refurb like this and
getting your hands dirty is going to be
a valuable skill that you need as a
property entrepreneur so 5 p.m. is when
your properties will be inspected and we
expect them to be done to a high
standard because you named the
so you have the cash you have the keys
we'll be having a boardroom meeting on
Monday evening where at least three
people from the losing team will be
evicted off you go good we need to sit
down with Ricky talk to Ricky about what
the plan is we can do it we can do it
yeah it's fine
you can do it okay spend the money in
McKees see you're not actually joking
are you there John because if Anthony
wasn't with you you probably would spend
see thousand pounds on our McDonald's so
all of the candidates off to take all of
that business gear up and slip into
something slightly more council a snake
taught me frantically rummaging delecia
perplexed by our own reflection and
here's one for the ladies and cindy
sensually removing a shirt nice patch
back air their little something to grab
onto baby and now revealing his
middle-aged dad bod in all of its glory
apparently pot bellies very much in this
season and here modeling in nineteen
nineties Lego spaceman t-shirt which if
you're under the age of 30 he'll have
absolutely no idea what about I'm loving
the shirt celebrating those Mother's Day
you can literally see the cogs in
Anthony's brain grinding and crunching
[Music]
this we just see what we can do Ty's
best friend over at the boys property
the massively undervalued two thousand
pound reverb is underway
[Music]
charli's for my coffee
so currently at the project that we sold
to an investor yesterday I was a person
that made the deal and made a decision
that the refurb could have been done
around 2,000 pounds it was a mistake and
hold up my hands and it's not a 2,000
pound refurb that's always what you want
to hear from your business mentor known
as hope make this hope so five of them
in this house they are running around
like headless chickens they do not have
a clue what they are doing
you got Rick here there who's just
wandering around like he's a lost you
got John who's faffing about with door
handles like he has no idea what you're
doing
you got Anthony who's like panicking
Hannah and Alicia I the only ones that
do anything they're cleaning the house
of the minute the boys frankly are
letting the girls down absolutely savage
answered he calls his mom to see if she
can lend him a helping hand this huge
reefer project and we've got like 48
hours to get it completed so kind of
neat my tools bring into New Castle is
there any chance you can bring them down
to me oh I'm a designate cleaner at the
moment and then I'm gonna help with
filling cracks and warm stuff and then
we're gonna paint as much as much as
possible while the boys get busy with
the deep clean let's pop over and pay a
visit to the girls team leader and see
is busy making sure that the budget is
in place before she goes and squashes
are all at one of her favorite hardware
stores which we can't name for copyright
reasons
three correct 1117 guys it's great so
gets T we are meanwhile James shows
around the lesser-known fourth member of
the bee gees about getting some new
carpets and of course what would a
property show be without a nice little
fear builders bomb a decorator is then
shown around to give the girls an idea
of what the painting is gonna cost tops
what are you just doing below the trees
we want it all white so if it's worth a
try and be done to top it no so you're
just gonna pay screen
what what what what is stripe off-white
and C and Danny do a supermarket sweep
looking for furnishings for their
property
[Music]
meanwhile back at the house while the
cat is away the mice will Ripley
absolutely piss out of that team leader
nc returns back sort of property after
has been cleaned up just pick the colors
or whatever and by the time I turned
around
tell her why she just got me home and
walked away and for me when somebody act
like that so I like let sleeping dogs
lie just to clarify the sleeping dog
that she's referring to we stood right
next to her so I just leave her to cool
down and then we carry on can I just say
please guys why we are here we need to
work respectfully with each other if
there is anything anybody knows you guys
don't like please don't go to cottony
and Beach behind that person I don't
like that I would flip so if there is
anything called corridors I'm not
sticking on you place and you don't like
it just say it lightly - everybody say
used to her don't go to gyms don't even
come to me let's address it we are one
family yeah that is the whole purpose of
teamwork so that's
okay after a decent night's sleep we're
back at the boys house to see how
they're getting on yeah we're in the
London we've done all of the we're
painting the whole house ourselves have
been any working day and night getting
all the painting done without to put two
two layers of coats on here obviously
from the noise you can hear now we've
got the painting done there's lots of
work going on we've got the carpets
going in this room here so they're just
laying that down there they did a great
job of that and it's gonna look so fresh
in there after I'll be honest we are all
probably I'll punch something if we
don't win his challenge because ever
would have won't be put in it's gonna
look good and then before it was an
overwhelming task for us yeah but once
we Club together as a team and we
started to see like results it spurred
us on knowing that we could do it we've
been ready to kill each other but the
thing is like Ricky's done a great job
at keeping the team's gather and
everybody's worked really hard and it
was absolutely fantastic so I'm so happy
with all the kids from being Q I spend
hundred and thirty six quid bass that
means we still got the three hundred
quid that we kept spare plus one hundred
and seventeen five hundred and sixty
something pound I didn't get door
handles they are so expensive there so
when we go out to try and get some
furnishings for the place I think we go
something like the range or be a noun or
something like that because I think we
just need to save a bit money didn't get
you two brushes because again they were
dead expensive and I just think the
money's probably better spent somewhere
else at the minute yeah right put that
yeah but I've been driven then all the
way up and over there
I don't know wardrobe they can literally
fit and then we can move trash frozen
wardrobe but this is yeah bedroom yeah
with the boys absolutely flying with
their refurb tasks there's a storm
brewing over with the girls I've
actually gone home today manager / team
leader has actually gone home today are
gong to do something with her business
okay think about it like we tried to
give her options as to try to encourage
us to stay and like leaders but she
never said and then James was went home
yesterday he arrived this yesterday
morning with us hung over stayed for an
hour and did nothing and then left
there's so much to do so busy at least
you got the shower sorted girls
everything was like this horrible color
so we're painting everything why all the
Woodworks being painted white at the
moment yeah so we've also have ripped up
the carpet from in here as well yeah
and again Woodworks being painted look
at the wall she picked out this she
picked out this dark
yes doubt yes though yeah yet yellow
mustard yellow but it was that dark
horrible kitchen has been bleached and I
can't believe and I sent her start
telling us we're not even allowed to
spend money while she's gone she's not
here she don't obviously don't care what
we do and she's telling us that we still
can't do anything when things need to be
done yes after having a nice relaxing
day off
James arrives back at the property with
his bushy little tail between his legs
[Music]
then I wore in here yeah yeah
MC needs to go whether we win or lose
because she was rubbish in the last task
when I was project manager she didn't do
anything and the things that she did do
she did wrong and she was too quiet
didn't stand up for herself at all and
then this time she's been put on the
spot as a project manager which makes
her look rubbish even more because you
can tell that it's rubbish because
nobody's project manager knows so she
needs to leave because I don't
understand how she is a successful
businesswoman when she can't manage a
project at all what did you do when you
went away
the thing is we've kinda say I know that
she don't realistically need the money
she's already told me she's got two
businesses and she does fairly well
she's got a Range Rover and her husband
has got loads of money so it's not even
like she needs to be here if red is the
colour of love oranges the colour of
absolute war and untold chaos as NC
returns back to the property oh you guys
oh my word has gone very far I mean am i
hello
balls - James what do you think of the
wall okay when we match it up drills bit
off everything everything in play ass I
think they beauty will come up I think I
liked it more when the bed is all more
free that one but do you think Jude is
the light
do you think students would like it you
guys would know you'd I said to these
like things like this alright let's do
what wait let's wait till tomorrow when
everything is it no I'm saying when
everything is here like the carpet here
and the blend goes up and how are we
going to do the dining and everything
you sit and say you know if we if we
don't win if we don't lose me if we
don't win do you worry that you're going
to get evicted
I'm not talking about not discussing
that right now about if I win or not I'm
just focusing I'm going to smoke us on
getting this ready well yeah you could
even talk more if you'd been here all
day the condition of eviction while we
doing here that's fine I'm just thinking
if you if you want it to get on with
stuff then you should have been here all
day it doesn't matter it does not my I
Russell knew everybody knew when you
asked me I have Danny when we did not
even know what we're going to do today
what did I say I said I'll be here
Friday Saturday but Sunday I'm going
when we did not even know that we were
going to be working weekend it would be
too fast so I'm telling you how we
fighting so no but you've been telling
you've been telling us you told us to
tell stuff to your face
so I'm just telling you how would what
feeling about the situation and we do it
like you never found that is that's
exactly you are quite right to extrude
to feel however you want to feel that's
within your right right now what it
doesn't actually add no value to me
right now what I said about Jay will you
let me finish sharply you not show that
me dude a shout that me why why are you
shouting at me
don't you dare shut up with talk to me
better talking to you when you're crazy
or just points at me look do not raise
your voice at me do this in my face
you're being do it listen you've had
your say wait wait listen I will not
speak to you I've said things about jr.
he said do not leave me finish me finish
excuse me let me wish you consider
you've already finished right well I was
trying to be honest with you you have
such a [ __ ] literally gouge my face
you're doing my head in
I'm trying to be honest with you but you
won't even let me speak you are swearing
at me you're just the worst project
manager we've ever ever could have had a
qualified nerves at me to know exactly
you okay five nos yeah watch your hand I
called you a [ __ ] yeah because you've
been a [ __ ] you're not letting me
finish you not let me talk you're not
talking yourself you can you shout it at
me and point it in your finger in my
face and shout at me Tommy not to shower
first I'm very very unhappy I've been
very respectful towards my colleagues if
anybody has something to say to one
another please say it to that person in
space I don't want this one in the
little corner talking about this one
this one in a little corner let's be
let's respect each other and deal with
each other respectfully I felt bullied I
felt ganged up without a doubt and I
felt so intimidated but I'm a strong
woman so I said till I had to do what I
had to do not nobody knows and say so
they pushed me but I maintain my cool
after letting everyone cool off for a
few minutes we arranged peace talks
within the group didn't really work out
that well to be honest what happened
yesterday it was the four of us
and you three literally ganged up on me
which was the intimidation which was
bullying but I don't I'm a very strong
woman
no one can no one can use whatever
tactics they want to use to push me
aside it doesn't work with me
so your attitude Cudney
yesterday we were extremely rude
throughout for you to turn round to me
and tell me that I was disrespectful to
you yesterday and I had a attitude
that's actually really horrible because
I did not I have the utmost respect for
you because you're the same age you're
the same age as my mom I have healthy
thoughts I'm talking and you are the
same age as my mum I've helped you with
everything I could help you with every
question every time you've asked me to
help you move your phone you know
numbers I've sent you pictures that
spoke to you I've sat with you have let
you sit down I came to your room the
other night we had a chat and so for you
to feel like I've been disrespectful to
you that's actually so wrong as if the
drama couldn't get any worse Danny drops
a whole tin of paint at the top of the
stairs oh my god
the argument between the girls lasted a
good hour and 45 minutes which we don't
have time to show but if you do want to
hear all you have to wait until the
district album drops in summer next year
and relax
the boys have finished their refurb in
time and on budget
I wonder 2,000 pounds this full bed HMO
has been given a new lease of wife by
the latter team which includes new
carpets painting throughout and a
blooming good scrub has been taken from
a tired old run-down student house to a
modern funky set of digs for a
relatively modest budget well every
warping decorate new carpets kitchen
some black things so I'm guessing five
five thousand to five thousand movie
believe it or not James they only spent
two thousand pounds no way there's no
chance I promise you mate they spent
about that's really this is like a
brand-new kitchen man this is crazy guys
an awesome job
they spent all of a bunch of 2000-pound
well it's just shows you what you can do
with a little bit of money and hard work
what's important hard work very good
very
even smells fresh doesn't YouTube hasn't
introduced smellivision yet alastair so
I wouldn't really know I'm speechless
absolutely speechless look what they've
even done to the windows now they didn't
have enough money in the budget to
replace the windows but they've repaired
the moon solid so let's not before you
bang in it was fall apart because it was
just so rotten on reflection I cannot
believe what they've done in the thymus
gars and how much they spent 2,000
pounds incredible really well done
I think the property will be worth an
extra one hundred and seventy pounds per
month in uplift and rent the boys invest
their big bad Trevor turns up sort of
house to see if the deal is worth
keeping because the reforms by both
teams have been done so quickly the
investors are still in their cooling-off
period meaning they can still pull out
of the deal if they're not happy with
the properties
alistair how you doing ma'am is this the
property Oh ice fantastic no bad not bad
that was the most Awkward hug between
two middle-aged men I've ever seen in my
life basically the refurbishment was
harvesting decoration throughout yeah
and a few odd repairs and he's gone HMO
isn't it yeah it's for a four-bed HMO
license required so it doesn't need any
okay eyes have gone for a bit of our
sort of our non-standard sort of white
water they've gone feature wall in the
bedroom yeah okay so let me ask a
question if I can so Alice Kay you know
when would the five have they had
experience of painting decorating before
ok honest having to do the reefer yep
you should have seen their faces drop
because I don't think any of them are
picked up
he brought in her life no that's it but
he's look again I can see what they
stand there doing that that's fine but
it's something like that you can see
there's a couple of rings on here and
you and I know with a bit of sandpaper a
little bit of filler that it said it's
not even a 10-minute job I don't know
what all right and it would make a big
difference 100% I can okay okay so look
Alison this is the new kitchen as per
the quotation refurbished kitchen well
that's an interesting point
okay now I have to say it's tighten it
up you know not bad I can see I'm not
sure if it's if it's Halden's or someone
like that I don't know on the
negotiation that I did okay and the
quotation was five and a half thousand
pounds which I've had a look at that
quotation and that clearly says two and
a half thousand pounds to be spent in
the kitchen from your kitchen so if I
was being if I was gonna buy this one I
would be majorly disappointed and I
would be pulling out and saying look
guys I'm sorry but the quotation as we
agreed two thousand pounds to the
standard of the five and a thousand
pounds that we agree yeah and the best
it can do with the money we've got
[Music]
despite arguing like an old married
couple he quite frankly despised the
sight of one another
the girls have completed their refurb
within their 1170 pound budget madruga
the investor is on her way down to check
up the work and decide if she still
wants to go ahead with the deal
meanwhile despite the three days of
constant arguing with one another the
girls are still going at it for the
point where NC won't even entertain a
conversation you've said stuff about me
but everybody agrees with me so you can
say stuff about me and my personality
and what kind of human being you think I
am but at the end of the day everyone
agrees with the opinions that I've heard
so your opinion is solitary just
scouring away the final shreds of any
dignity that remains clearly you lacking
the understanding here in this whole
situation do you not think that's your
issue that's your problem not ours we
asked our mate James who's a local leg
agent specializing in HMOs to have a
look around and tell us what he thinks
yep so I've come back and had a look
around have worked out how much they
spent and then I can't see some good
winds and the property it's a nice
flooring in the hallway which is nice
and welcoming and the bathrooms I'm you
know good improvement good floor and
they've done some repairs to the
showerhead however I'm a little bit
disappointed overall not every room has
been decorated some rooms definitely did
that me decorating this blu-tack still
visible on a wall and in one of the
bedrooms the skirting board did needed
painting desperately and that it's an
average job the girls business mental
Russell and his brother Samuel come to
have a look at the girls finished
property I'm not loving it
the floors very average but look at this
it's just bubbly and the cracks are
still there can't really see this
doesn't this doesn't not feel high-end
what are they actually done in here this
this doesn't mean paint it house it okay
well I'm hoping that the other rooms are
better
what have they actually done I know
they've done this
to the wall another way of dealing with
that whole event I personally think
that's genius
have they done the curtains are the same
everything about this room apart from it
looks a little bit tidier picture and
focuses right
okay whoopee there okay I can see that
the kitchens a bit cleaner but we could
have paid someone 10 pounds an hour for
a few hours to clean ah well they have
changed the shower but again how long
does that take the floor have I changed
the floor have I changed a thank God all
right but the bathroom before wasn't the
worst room in the house I mean how much
how much money and time does it cost to
put to put some flooring in a bathroom a
change of shower not that much I can
only imagine that after the whole house
being a complete mess up until now that
this room there's moving better bloody
impress Michael from a pretty good all
right so they've got a new carpet good
what they've done is they've tried to go
for a feature wall but the thing is if
you're going to paint the wall right
orange you need to at least have the
cushions to match not an off orange that
makes my balls itch and yeah I remember
that it was here in the bedroom there we
get rid of it replace it or should we
improve it just got rid of it so
basically then all they've done with
this room is they've unfurnished it and
made the wall look like sick and this is
the room that was supposed to impress us
and it's average combined with all the
argument if I was one of the three that
had stayed sewing right well I'm angry
right now I don't know what midoriko is
gonna think of this but I personally
Viper's madruga
I wouldn't be too happy speak of the
devil she's at the front
let me show you around they're coming in
thank you sir they're made of quite a
lot of changes first of all this floor
beforehand this is a horrible sort of
dirty grubbing moldy forever completely
replaced it what is this floor okay
they've also painted it completely yeah
so if you come through my grandma's this
is a lot tidier and nicer than many that
he was before all cleaned and fresh I
thought it was gonna have new furniture
wasn't that on their plan
yeah not included in this quote this was
the library first though with it was
that they did not have it matches look
I'd have expected the boys to do this
not the girls oh it's awful is that one
of the girls known for doing interior
design that was one of her big things
that's what that's what hooked me in
yeah because she said that's what she
specializes in I actually thought that
this would look amazing this is the
living area I mean sort of before was on
a cardboard box in the wall it's not
much better isn't it I mean yeah there
was that hole in the wall which then we
still covered with this event well I
mean that's creative but it's awful it's
really bad okay look so there is this
what is this I mean you would box that
in looks awful but it also looks really
dangerous I mean it's just I was I don't
know what I was expecting but it's not
high-end is that
I mean it was sold as high-end the whole
thing is dangerous we save the best to
lower your expectations right now and
then I don't build them up at the end I
think they're pretty low no this is the
largest room this would be they've
really got you the most most rent this
is painted it's color coordinate like
this - it's the first time but look look
at that color coordinated almost color
coordinated was that that was my expects
that orange also for me I just see
what's on the presentation because
that's what I was sold
yeah well that's a very good point that
is it you know I don't have an
expectation of what it was like or what
it isn't I have the expectation of what
I was sold and I feel like they're
missile I think it's awful the
presentation did not show this at all
and personally I think that I should be
speaking to the people responsible yeah
I definitely have questions for them why
I've been missile right now yeah
it's like watching them all solemnly
walk to the electric chair so I'm really
very disappointed in this property it is
not what was sold on the presentation
that you guys did I know the decoration
was included and I know that you took
particularly focused on how good you
were at interior design and making
everything look lovely I I've seen
cracks I've seen those doors are not
fire doors which was in the presentation
you had sent there were fire doors
there's no smoke alarm in this room the
room next door there has not been
touched there is it's not been painted
nothing's been done to it it's really
old so we tried to do as much as we can
in the property and we did the flooring
which was not really included in the
plan that they gave us just for now
because we were not given the full
amount for the refurb we were given just
a part which was for painting in the
shower but we wanted to do the flooring
as well only because it was really
really old
look at this I mean you tell me you guys
you have you do property look look at
these what to this level no absolutely
not
that's cracks well that color is awful
it reminds me of a very cheap airline
paint brush is dry in
Esther's reviewed but who'll get a
dressing-down
in the boardroom
[Music]
right usually I'm in a pretty good mood
this time of day I can't say I'm in a
particularly great mood tonight after
seeing the state of what I saw this
evening and since 10:00 got a very very
simple job a very very simple job which
is just to decorate the house there's
six of you you had four days to do it
and you messed up completely messed up
Ricky's team you put yourself in an
impossible situation by massively
massively under estimating the cost of a
refurb of the house you promise there'll
be a new kitchen in there that wasn't
Trevor's been around your house tonight
Madrid care has been mine your house
tonight and I can't say it was an easy
job for me having to face them after the
mess that we have experienced tonight at
least three of you will be evicted
tonight madruga around the house tonight
did she seem happy no do you think that
was justified yes all right Trevor went
Manuel house tonight and he was
disappointed that there was no kitchen
new kitchen like like was promised
however when we asked Trevor if he
wanted to go ahead with the deal based
on what you told told he said yes so
he's overall he's happy all I went
around the house tonight and to be
honest with the budget that you are
working with I have to say I was very
impressed the property will seem a very
high standard and it looked to me like
it was it was ready to let I'm actually
a little bit amazed with the standard
considering you massively underestimated
the budget 2000-pound I thought it was
going to be an absolute eyesore I
thought it was going to be a disgrace
but it was done up to a very very high
standard Ricky you're on very thin ice
last challenge and I almost evicted you
and I actually regretted not evicting
you
however as team leader of this task I'm
very impressed
so as a result of your four days all of
you stayed in the house for four days
you work very very long hours it's paid
off
Trevor's happy the deals going ahead so
as a treat
think you deserve a spa night where you
can have some massages enjoy a spa so
off you go
you're safe back to the house and you
can go and enjoy your spa nc's team you
know you messed up at least three of you
will be evicted tonight I want you to
figure out and talk between yourselves
and come back and tell me who's
responsible off you go everything that I
was asked to do I did if we had the full
budget I would no we won't deliver what
we said we will I think there's the
project lacked a team leader so I would
so person responsible is anything I
don't even know where to start
if I ask James you left the property and
left the girls working got drunk I don't
even think you care if you get through
this round or not Kirsty you also left
NC Abbey
we'll both shouting each other
hot-headed Danny I don't know what you
were thinking with that wall watching
the footage and hearing what what
Alastair and the guys had to say I was
worried that there was gonna be a
physical fight you had to paint a house
that was it paint a house you had a
budget that you set the budget to paint
the house for you messed around you
didn't paint the house you argued I
would agree with what Abby said no at no
point that I think that anybody knew
what they were meant to be doing what
role was theirs on Friday what what
shocks me about this is on Friday you
guys had by far the easier of the two
properties to do by by a mile James
who's on the other team was La Table
we're so I feel sorry for them they're
never able to do it you had the easiest
task I love you on the fryer
and it was everything was going to find
let's do is paint and decorate the house
when I came back to sue today I was I
saw you shouting each other and the
footage on a hearse and looking at what
you guys have actually achieved and why
how how have they screwed this up so
much I was showing vahik around I was
embarrassed of the house because she was
saying this isn't what we say yeah
you're right it isn't I'm just
flabbergasted flabbergasted no one knew
what to do no one knew the budget why
did none of you have a clue yeah
and see as to as team leader do you take
responsibility for this task being a
miserable file well I do because extent
well it was a miserable fail you a team
leader you were shouting in people's
faces so then say you're evicted please
leave who should be evicted Koster who
filled this task
you're evicted please leave but at least
one more person needs to go tonight
who's it going to be took him we just
have a name like Mike honest you've got
20,000 pound on the line here can we
just have a named courtly calling out of
the four of you I'm most confident about
you this week you're safe go back to the
house
Donnie you've tried your best your best
is not being good enough you've not
given me a good reason why you shouldn't
be evicted so with regret you're evicted
please leave James I'm not happy I'm not
happy that you've abandoned the ladies
I'm not happy with your work ethic but I
have seen an improvement in your
attitude Abby you did really good with
the first challenge I'm not happy with
how he's been shouting Lea Nancy's face
I think it's ridiculous I think you need
to take your emotions out of it you are
both on thin ice get back to the castle
we all agreed that we didn't really have
good leadership in that task
unfortunately this is how it panned out
but that doesn't reflect in my work I
think any way whatsoever my voice needed
to be hid I needed to let them know that
the bullying tactics the ganged up and
the intimidation this woman nobody stops
me nobody intimidates me I do not stand
for bully so Nora great
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next time on the eviction and do think
we can get up with endearing today how
much us a nice
-
[Music]
that would be decorative
[Music]
[Music]
you